letztere warten wird was geht hier zur
anni und ihr seht mich nach langer zeit
mal wieder vor der kamera und nicht nur
einfach in gameplays oder so ich bin
hier gerade mit meinem match und wir
sind hier in unserem ort produktionsraum
hier ist sebastian computer mit seinem
pc und hinten ist meinte sie
da liegt auch das trockene sommer
zugestimmt hat wollt ihr eigentlich für
sein verhalten
dank kräftig gebaut dass man sich
eigentlich für die for production habe
aber es ist ein cooles teil auf jeden
fall
ich weiß es jetzt im nordsee oder
bewusst jetzt übrigens hingeht
dafür produzierte da noch vor gefahren
um 12 uhr heute nacht los wurde habt ihr
herz oder vielleicht sogar mein kopf
nein nein
was hier noch sagen wollte dieses video
kommt auch weil ich einerseits stress
zweiten zwar heute keine ware kommen
kann
das liegt daran dass wir eine folge zu
wenig produziert haben
da ich ja noch auf der rückreise war von
der abfahrten da können wir nicht
aufnehmen und damit wir da nicht aus
dieser dicken aufnahmesessions bayern
ist es jetzt einfach so dass wir keine
folge mehr aufgenommen haben
vielmehr gibt es eigentlich gar nichts
zu sagen es dazu jetzt auch was ich noch
sagen wollte wir werden heute nacht
irgendwann zwischen elf und fünf auf
deutschen autobahnen unterwegs sein
von süden nach einer fan treffen auf
jeden fall stellt euch n texte und
stellte auf die autobahn herausstellen
dann sind sehen wir uns richtig auf trab
cosmo gen raps entscheidung gegen
referenten worldwide lila luftballon
gang lieder luftballon lulatsch lgl
julius markt statt
was kriegt hier gar nicht die kann man
gewartet so mache also so ein bisschen
ein bisschen bisschen hässlich aber
dafür kann ja auch nichts dafür ist ja
in unserer familie die die ganze die
nissan okay leute zahlen nochmal letzten
chips
was ist jetzt noch mal catches hier die
gute erste aus dem türkischen supermarkt
damit kochen können richtig und ja das
ist auf jeden fall selbst range was hier
mache das besser journalist anschaffung
dieses komische switcher kann kein nein
ich weiß ein ladekabel das medium radio
free asia oder es werden wahrscheinlich
auf loks von dort fort leipzig kommen
weil ich zu wenig produziert habe im
gegensatz zu diesem jungen tut
allerdings ist das internet allerdings
gesundheit warum allerdings nicht da wo
wir hinfahren relativ city was irgendwie
das ganze wird ist auf der gamescom
blablabla blut ist auch da
social medias darf ab
unten in der beschreibung